Ja, gut.
Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Rana Yüksel. Ich bin auf dieser Station Assistenz Arstin tätig.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschickreif führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache mir hilft jemand.
Ja, bevor wir anfangen, würde gerne Ihnen ein paar gemeine Fragen schütteln.
Gemeine?
Gemeine Frage.
Ich dachte schon, Sie stellen mir Gemeine Fragen.
Ja, über Iran, über die Person, die ich hatte.
Die Person, die ich hatte. Ja klar, die müssen Sie wissen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Birgit Bekar.
Können Sie sich über die Kontenziation der
Frau Bekar.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Bekar?
Ich bin 58.
Wie alt sind Sie, genau geboren?
Am 15. August 66.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58.
Ich bin 56.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 73.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
Ungefähr 62 kg.
Frau Bekar, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für mich warten Sie im Moment?
Ich habe mit einmal
gestern so richtig angefangen,
habe ich ganz heftige Schmerze in der linken Leiste.
Das krampft sich alles immer so zusammen.
Das wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Das strahlt auch in das Bein rein.
Und auch so ein bisschen in den Rücken.
Was ganz komisch ist, ich habe auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl,
dass ich mich nicht mehr in die Reise habe.
Ich bin kurzatmisch.
Sind Sie schon auf dem Platz?
Ja, das hat plötzlich angefangen.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass ich meine Mutter hatte?
Solche Beschwerden hatte ich nicht.
Ich muss allerdings dazu sagen,
dass ich nicht mehr auf dem Platz war.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich meine Mutter hatte.
Solche Beschwerden hatte ich nicht.
Ich muss allerdings dazu sagen,
dass ich vor vier Wochen
an dem Bein ein Lymphknoten entfernt wurde.
Und ein Melanomis entfernt wurde.
Jetzt habe ich,
seit zwei Wochen läuft ich Chemotherapie.
Jetzt ist mir sowieso schon immer wahnsinnig schlecht.
Ich habe auch die üblichen Nebenwirkungen.
Es geht mir wirklich nicht gut.
Aber jetzt sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und meine Arzt ist im Urlaub.
Deswegen bin ich gleich hierher gekommen.
Wer ist Ihr Hochschorst, Frau Wilker?
Das ist Doktor.
Ich bin der Hochschorst.
Das ist Doktor Schruyra.
Sie haben heftige Schmerzen,
die ein linkeralste.
Sie haben ein sehr starker Schmerz.
Sie haben einiges mitgemacht.
Wir alle brauchen wieder einen Schmerz.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, dass ich das nicht schreibe.
Ich würde sagen, dass ich das nicht schreibe.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, warum das mit angefangen hat.
Gleichzeitig ist die Lampenotenantrag, die Lampenotenantrag, verfolgt worden.
Gleichzeitig mit dem Melanom ist vor vier Wochen der Lymphkneunen entfernt worden.
Ist Ihnen ein Viehbauch aufgefahren?
Ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht vielbrich, nie.
Sonst wurde krank, aber vielbrich nur nicht, nie.
Ist Ihnen etwas aufgefahren, z.B. geschwollene Bauch?
Das einzige, was ich wirklich sagen kann,
das hängt mit der Chemotherapie zusammen.
Ich habe Nasenbluten und ich bin wahnsinnig schlapp.
Ich fühle mich total erschöpft.
Ich habe in den letzten acht Wochen 4 kg abgenommen.
Ich habe in sechs Wochen.
Ich fühle mich nicht ständig.
Aber als ich gemerkt habe, dass ich das runtergehe,
habe ich mich häufiger auf die Ware gestellt.
Das ist nicht wirklich gut zur Zeit.
Leiden Sie unter gleichzeitig Bauchschmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen nicht müh.
Wie sieht es mit dem Stuhlgang aus?
Haben Sie Probleme damit?
Leiden Sie unter Durchfall oder Verstoffung?
Das hat man immer mal wieder, aber jetzt im Augenblick gerade geht es.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ist Ihnen ein bisschen schlecht?
Haben Sie sich schon erbrochen?
Ja, es ist mir nur schlecht.
Manchmal könnte ich mich übergeben, dass es mir hinterher besser geht.
Aber mir ist nur ständig übel.
Wie war die OP konflikationslos verlaufen?
Ja, so viel ich weiß.
Ist da alles völlig problemlos gelaufen?
Ja, deswegen habe ich mich beim Arzt besorgt.
Natürlich bin ich in der Nachsorge.
Jetzt ist mein Arzt nicht da.
Jetzt sind diese Schmerzen mit einmal aufgetreten.
Die machen mir schon ein bisschen.
Sie haben schon Erwandt, Sie haben Atemnot.
Gleichzeitig Husten.
Ich habe nur dieses Gefühl.
Vor allem wenn ich mich ein bisschen anstrengle.
Sind Ihnen Herzrausen, Herzklopfen, Herzstorfen aufgefallen?
Nein.
Wie schlafen Sie, Frau Bika?
Nicht wirklich, aber schon längere Zeit nicht.
Ich bin ein bisschen unruhig, kann schlecht einschlafen.
Wenn ich nachts aufwache, kann ich auch nicht wieder einschlafen.
Nein, meine Nachtruhe ist nicht so gut.
Ich habe etwas gegen die Störungen eingenommen.
Nein, ich versuche, etwas, das sich mir Musik anhört.
Ich bringe mich selber zur Ruhe.
Aber Medikamente nehme ich da nicht.
Was habe ich alles nicht?
Was hab ich alles nicht?
Ich habe alles nicht.
Sie hatten Melono, wo genau?
Am linken Oberschenkel war das.
Am linken Oberschenkel.
Im linken Oberschenkel nach der OP ist ihnen etwas Ungewöhnliches aufgeführt.
Aufgeführt.
Ich war ganz erstaunt, dass die Walp variability dumpf ist, ja?
Sie haben keine Vorarl-Granfungen auf, ja?
Nee, sonst habe ich nichts.
Dieser Schrecker hat mir durchaus gereicht.
Jetzt bin ich nicht so Sorgen, weil ich mit einmal Schmerzen habe, die ich sonst noch nie hatte.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Wenn ich Schmerzen habe, auch nach der OP, habe ich die Bürophäen bekommen.
Dann sollte ich die Bürophäen nehmen, damit es mir gar nicht schlecht geht.
Auf gleichsatz, bekommen Sie auf Chemotherapie?
Ja, genau.
Sie haben eine OP?
Nein, als Kind habe ich die Malben rausgekommen.
Sie haben eine OP, die ich auf Chemotherapie habe.
Also bekannt ist nicht.
Ich hoffe auch nicht, dass da noch mal irgendetwas rausgekommen ist.
Aber ich habe keine Allergien.
Nein, gar nichts.
Sie haben eine OP, die ich auf Chemotherapie habe.
Sie haben eine Lebensmittelallergien.
Ich kann alles erst mal trinken.
Super.
Frau Wecker, jetzt möchte ich überlebensgewohnheiten, Einfragen stellen.
Brauchen Sie?
Nein, ich bin nicht hauhaumen.
Super. Trinken Sie Alphohol?
Hin und wieder trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, aber eigentlich eher selten.
Prohohe oder wie meine ich Sie?
Bitte?
Sie trinken 1-2 Gläser Wein, Prohohe können wir sagen.
Nein, ach, wenn ich 2 Gläser im Monat trinke, ist das 4.
Ach, okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht, Frau Sornig.
Ich muss eine Patientin fragen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen, Frau Wecker?
Nein, nein, Drogen habe ich noch nie probiert.
Nun kommen wir zur Erfremdung der Familie Alamnese.
Wie ist die Erfremdung?
Nein, mein Vater ist tatsächlich mit 76 Anlungenkrebs gestorben.
Das ist natürlich auch so ein Vorbild.
Der hat natürlich stark geraucht und das fand ich immer so schlimm.
Ich habe nie mit dem Raufen angefangen.
Meine Mutter hat einen Schlaganfall.
Es ist halbseitig gelehmt und auf den Rollstuhl angewiesen.
Sie ist schon in Mitleidenschaft gezogen.
Sie erholt sich zwar immer noch ein bisschen und wird so ganz langsam,
aber es wird besser, sie hat viel Energie.
Aber ganz gut wird es bestimmt nicht mehr, weil ja.
Ist Ihr Mutter für dich momentan?
Ja, ganz alleine kommt sie nicht recht zu recht,
ein bisschen Unterstützung braucht sie schon.
Also nicht direkt Pflege bei vielen Sachen.
Aber grundlegend muss schon immer mal wieder jemand nachgeguckt.
Wie lange hat sie das vorhanden?
Ich hatte sie ja irgendwas,
aber wir haben das nicht vorgefällt,
haben wir das nicht gewusst, was mit ihr ist?
Oder dass sie irgendwas hat?
Wie alt ist ihr Mutter?
69, war sie, als sie ihren Schlaganfall hatte.
Das heißt, jetzt ist sie auf dem Blick, wie alt ist sie?
Lassen Sie mich rechnen.
Sie muss dem auf dem Blick, muss man erneuten.
Ja, sie ist 82.
83.
Frau Biko, sind Sie für heiratet?
Ich bin heiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter habe ich, ja.
Ist Ihr Tochter gesund?
Sie ist gesund, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin angestellte bei der Stadt,
also öffentliche Ninsicht, arbeite beim Einwohner-Melderamt.
Wo genau?
Beim Einwohneramt, also beim Bürgeramt der Stadt.
Okay.
Haben Sie die Trist bei der Arbeit?
Ja, hin und wieder.
Manche Tage ist es schon stressig.
Jetzt kurz vor der Urlaubzeit, wollen alle ihre Piste verlängern
und ihre Ausweise.
Aber eigentlich sind wir ein gutes Team
und ich gehe eigentlich jeden Tag gerne zur Arbeit.
Mhm.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der Listen-Site im Ausstand?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Der Urlaub liegt noch vor uns, ja.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft?
Sind wir gegen Covid?
Ja, gegen Covid.
Da bin ich viermal sogar geimpft, ja.
Okay.
Und im letzten Winter habe ich diese Grippeimpfung gemacht,
das mache ich eigentlich jedes Jahr,
weil ich auch viel Kontakt habe, damit ich mir da nichts einfange.
Mhm.
Ja, sind Sie oft krank geworden?
Sind Sie oft krank geworden?
Hatten Sie häufiger Erkrankungen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wie gesagt, dadurch, dass ich so viel Kundenkontakt habe,
also ein Bürgerkontakt,
gehen ja viele Menschen aus und ein bei uns im Büro.
Deswegen mache ich immer die Grippeimpfung, ne?
Mhm, okay.
Frau Biko, möchtest Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerte?
Nein, das reicht mir auch völlig.
Mir ist schlecht und ich habe diese Schmerzen, also...
Das merkt mich schon ein bisschen, ja.
Mhm.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Haben Sie zum Beispiel Hautveränderungen bemerkt?
Nein.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht.
Also außer dieser Hautveränderung am Bein,
die mir jetzt so viel Ärger gemacht hat,
habe ich immer nix gemerkt, ne?
Mhm, okay.
In der linken Seite, in der linken, neusten...
Es gibt keine Schwierungen, ja.
Ich habe da jetzt nicht irgendwie rumgedrückt
oder getastet oder so.
Ich habe nur gemerkt, es tut mir einmal richtig doll weh, ne?
Und es wird halt irgendwie immer mehr.
Mhm.
Haben Sie Druckgefühl im Bauch?
Druckgefühl im Bauch?
Ja.
Die Bauchschmerzen nehmen Sie nicht, ne?
Mhm, ja.
Also wenn überhaupt ein Streit ist so in den Rücken
und in das Bein.
Mhm, in den Bein.
Haben Sie Taupatsgefühl oder Kreberl in den Bein?
Nee, nee, also auf den Bein.
Also da kann ich laufen, da habe ich kein Taupatsgefühl.
Mhm.
Ja, treiben Sie Sport regelmäßig?
Ja, ich habe eigentlich regelmäßig ein bisschen Sport gemacht.
Aber jetzt durch diese Operation musste ich das ein bisschen einstellen, natürlich, ne?
Mhm.
Wie viel bekommen Sie, oder haben Sie Chemotherapie bekommen?
Wie viel mal?
Ich habe jetzt, einmal vor zwei Wochen haben wir angefangen, vier Sitzungen.
Vier Sitzungen, okay.
Nach der Chemotherapie, wie füllen Sie sich?
Ja, von Mal zu Mal schlechter natürlich, ja, klar.
Deswegen sagte ich ja, so mir ist übel und ich fühle mich schlapp und...
Ja, okay.
Aufgrund ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden haben Sie etwas nicht genommeln, ja?
Einige genommeln.
Ich habe etwas nicht genommen.
Schmerzmedikamente.
Ja, ich habe mal Ibuprofen genommen, weil ich das ja regelmäßig sowieso nehme.
Aber diese Schmerzen hilft es nicht.
Ja, nicht geholfen.
Ja, das war meine Frage, Frau Wecker.
Warten Sie hier im Wartesmal?
Und ich rufe Sie, ja, werde ich Sie natürlich für eine Unterzucht suchen.
Und gleichzeitig Blut abnehmen.
Danach können wir nochmal über die Ergebnisse und die Behandlung widersprechen, okay?
Ja, wunderbar, das stimmt gut, ja.
So, jetzt wieder die große Frage.
Möchte jemand zusätzlich noch etwas wissen von der Frau?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Wann sind Sie letzten Mal zur Onkologie oder zum Hausarzt gegangen?
Vor zwei Wochen.
Okay, und seit wann haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, Sie haben seit gestern Schmerzen, aber...
Und die Atemnot ist eigentlich auch jetzt gekommen, also in den letzten Tagen?
Letzten Tagen.
Und davor haben Sie keine Atemnot, richtig?
Ja, davor hatte ich das nicht, ne?
Okay, genau.
Brust, Schmerzen haben Sie?
Ich habe das noch gefragt, ob ich Herz oder Brustmatter, ich kriege nur keine Luft, ne?
Okay.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenart, Artregalmäßig?
Ja, zur Krebsversorgung, ich regalmäßig, ja.
Wann war die letzte Besuch?
Oh, das ist so ein dreiviertel Jahr her.
Und war alles in Ordnung?
Damals war alles in Ordnung, ja.
Okay, und leiden Sie unter Nachtschweins?
Nein, eigentlich muss ich nicht schwitzen in der Nacht, ne?
Okay, danke.
Okay.
Können wir schon?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Nach dem OP und der Chemotherapie, haben Sie,
Lungen, S Purple oder HiermThese~?
Sie могли auch rausfinden.
Das wurde damals gemacht, praktisch noch vor der Operation.
Okay.
Danke.
Also wenn Sie mögen?
Ich, die fünfLungen?
Ich möchte, bevor Sie gleich anfangen mit Ihrem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Es gibt bei Ihnen ein kleines Problem mit der Verständigung.
Und so versuchen Sie mal, die Sprache von hinten aus dem Hals nach vorne in den Mund zu bekommen.
Das ist total schwer, wenn ich das jetzt so beschreibe.
Aber die sprechen sogar hinten im Hals.
Und da fehlt die Artikulation so ein bisschen.
Wenn Sie sich bewusst machen, wo Silbenbildung und Lautbildung passiert, es ist hier vorne im Mund.
Und machen Sie mal den Versuch, die Sprache nach vorne in die Nase und vorne in den Mund zu holen.
Das klingt jetzt total komisch.
Aber es war für mich sehr auffällig, dass ich Sie wirklich nicht gut verstehen konnte.
Und jetzt haben wir noch eine Chance, wir sprechen noch mal eine Viertelstunde zusammen.
Da können wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen etwas daran arbeiten.
Ich sage Ihnen das, weil ich das gelernt habe.
Ich singe im Chor und seit ich denken kann.
Und da ist die Stimmbildung immer ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Und da geht es immer darum, wo sitzt die Stimme?
Unsere Resonanzräume sind hier oben.
Und die Laute bilden wir hier vorne im Mund.
Und die Verständlichkeit ist sehr viel besser, wenn Sie das versuchen, ein bisschen nach vorne zu holen.
Also ich hoffe, Sie müssen jetzt keinen Kopfstand machen deswegen.
Wenn ich ausgelegtes bin, dann späche ich sehr schlecht.
Sie sprechen gar nicht schlecht, Sie machen eigentlich ganz wenig Fehler.
Es ist nur diese Geschichte, dass die Stimme so hinten im Rachen sitzt.
Und wenn Ihnen das gelingt, dann musst ein bisschen nach vorne zu holen.
Wenn es jetzt nicht klappt, üben Sie abends vor dem Spiegel, morgens vor dem Spiegel.
Ich glaube, es wäre für Sie ein großer Fortschritt.
Gut, jetzt.
Ja, jetzt möchte ich.
Guten Tag Frau Oberstein.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen diesen Fall besprechen.
Ja, natürlich.
Schmerzen, in den linken Lärchen mit Altstrahlung in den Beinen und Rücken.
Nur das eine Bein?
Nur in einen Bein, ne?
Ja, in den Beinen.
In den linken Bein.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit fünf von zehn bewahrt.
Die Patient beschrieb die Schmerzen als dürrkend und schitechend.
Diese Schmerzen sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und außerhalb der Patienten berichtete, dass sie vier Wochen bei der Patientin
Luftnoten entfernt wurden.
Und die Patientin hat vier Wochen Chemotherapie erhört.
Aufgrund des Melanons.
Und sie klagte über die Nasenblut, Epistaxi, und nausea, so wie auf Fatik.
Die Fragen nach Emises, Fieber, Ödem, Rötung in der Betrofenanzeite wurden verneint.
Desweiteren klagte sie über auf Dispne.
Die vegetative Anamnese sei bis auf Inapetans, auf Gewichtverlust von 4 kg in 8 Wochen
und in Sonne informe Ein- schlafstörung.
Unaufheilig.
Reise Anamnese war auf unaufheilig.
Die Patient sei verständlich geimpft auf 4 Mal Corona, Covid-19.
Letztes Jahr auf Gebriefeinfunk aufgefischt, lasse die Patientin.
Die Patientin habe letztes Jahr auch die Grippe im Zoo bekommen.
Ja.
Es bestehen keine Vorerkrankungen.
Medikamente nehmen sie bei Bedarf nur Ibuprofen ein.
Dieses Mal habe sie auf eingenommen, aber das hat ihnen nicht geholfen.
Hat ihnen nicht geholfen, okay.
Als Kind sei Tronseliktorien durchgeführt worden,
bei ihr keine Allergie bekannte.
Und sie haben auch keine Unfallträglichkeiten.
Die Patientin sei nicht rauchherr- rin, nicht rauchherr- rin.
Und trinke 1 bis 2 Gwiese-Waay pro Monat.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneut.
Sie hat von so rund 80 Jahren gelitten.
Sie hatte auch Parise, aber seit leichter Pflege durfte.
Sie ist auf 89 Jahre alt.
Die Patientin ist verheiratet.
Sie hat eine Gesunde getroffen.
Sie hat die Patientin ange- schietert in Burgampt.
Sie ist aufgrund der Personalmangel.
Sie hat eine Patientin, aber sie hat nicht getroffen.
Sie hat die Patientin ange- schietert in Burgampt.
Die Patientin ist verhe LEDs.
Aufgrund der Chemotherapie.
Das könnte es auch sein, ja. Was könnte es auch noch sein?
Ja, diese Schmerzen in den Linken leisten, aber unverschaligt, aber das muss ich sagen.
Ja, in Gönal herrne, aber...
Ja, diese Zeptome sprechen nicht für in Gönal herrne, keine Schwerung und so weiter.
Das könnte es auch sein.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Ja, das ist auch ein Wort.
Das könnte es auch sein.
Auf Alefeli? Ja, genau.
Alefeli.
Was befindet sich denn diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Das ist für die Patienten, die sich auf die Hand schmieren.
Wo auch? Achten Sie da besonders?
Ja, diese leichten Bereiche, rücken Bereiche, taste ich auf.
Ja, genau. Da wäre jetzt noch tatsächlich ein denkbares Problem,
dass es da doch von der Patientin unbemerkt, vielleicht eine Wunde,
was mich in Ordnung ist.
Es würde man aber gar sofort sehen.
Also normalerweise merkt ein Patient, dass es natürlich auch,
wenn eine Wunde etwas nicht ist.
Also die Patientin hat schon erwähnt, dass diese Wunde gut gehalten ist.
Aber trotzdem müssen wir normalerweise kontrollieren.
Genau.
Zum Beispiel, wenn es eine Schwerung oder Vergrößerung gibt,
müssen wir auch kontrollieren.
Trotzdem möchte ich den Bauch auch abhören und abtasten.
Natürlich, dann die Lunge höre ich auch ab.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab.
Insbesondere werde ich als Fündungsfaremeter,
C.R.C., W.S.G., Blutbild und Leberwarte, Nierenwarte überprüfen.
Vergattet aus Lunge und Leberwarte, was machen Sie dann noch?
Ja, die Dimash.
Die Dimash ist die wichtigste.
Muss ich auf den Gerinnungsfaremeter überprüfen.
Genau.
Dann werde ich natürlich ein Bild geben,
das für alle Verhandlungen wie Rontgen Torax veranlust.
Ja, auf alle Fälle genau.
Rontgen Torax auf Rontgen des Abtomans auf.
Dann vielleicht um freie Flüssigkeit, freie Luft unter der Diaphratma.
Können wir sehen im Teechen rücken.
Aber es ist unwahrscheinlich auf.
Aber wenn diese Metastase in Wirbelsöhre gibt,
werde ich auf Rontgen, LVS und S.Y.A. veranlust.
Werte ich auf Ultra-Schalia Abtomans,
das wird man im Vorfeld schon machen.
Beim Rahmen der ersten Untersuchung, das man so viel macht.
Nicht nur den Bauch, sondern insbesondere auch die Leiste.
Die Leiste, insbesondere die Leiste.
Gegebenenfalls vielleicht Pet,
um Metastase zu bestimmen.
Genau, das mal gucken, ob er doch noch etwas über ist.
Ja.
Gut, dann bin ich gespannt.
Was machen wir, wenn die mit der Stasierung hat?
Die Therapie richtet sich nach der Ergibnisse und klinische Untersuchung.
Vielleicht müssen wir die Chemo-Terapie weiter durchführen.
Oder vielleicht auch sogar anpassen.
Oder absetzen, dann warten wir vielleicht.
Also zumindest unkologisches Konzil.
Ja, natürlich.
Für diesen Fall möchte ich unbedingt unkologisches Planen.
Weil dieser Fall ist sehr kompliziert für mich.
Deswegen, ja.
Jetzt kommt gerade ein Hinweis.
Intangivstation und Isolieren.
Können Sie uns ganz kurz erklären, warum Isolieren?
Ich habe nicht genau sagen Isolieren.
Ein Kollege hat das gerade eingelendet.
Vielleicht Immerschweche wegen.
Ah, deswegen.
Ja, okay, dann macht es Sinn.
Also, die Chemo-Terapie, deswegen.
Ja, natürlich.
Und Immerschweche, deswegen.
Ist so einiges besser.
Stationen aufmachen, auch wichtig.
Ja, gut.
Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
dass man mit der Patientin ist.
Und dann schauen wir uns die Nachher an.
Haben wir ein Bett frei?
Ja, okay.
Das ist ja eine Frage.
Wir müssen unbedingt vereinbaren.
Ich glaube, dass schon wir haben freie Plätze für diesen Fall.
Dann nehmen wir die Stationär auch.
Gut, wir sprechen später noch mal.
Alles klar.
Ja, in diesem Fall, ja, eine stationäre Aufnahme ist notwendig.
Und dann geht es um die Weiteran-Akulierung.
Das ist wichtig.
Und natürlich so Überwachung.
Weil ich habe nicht richtig gedacht,
ich habe nur Sie jetzt noch etwas haben.
Ja, Sie haben eigentlich schon eine Verdacht,
Sie haben gesagt, Sie vermuten,
dass es am ersten Ebene,
die Metastasenbildung ist.
Und das muss man jetzt dann ausschließen.
Das muss ja auch eine Nebenwirkung der Chemo sein.
Das wäre ja der beste Fall eigentlich.
Gut, und ein Rundinfekt könnte es sein.
Aber dafür sprechen eigentlich keine Aussagen der Patientin.
Also da war eigentlich nichts, was da in die Richtung passte.
Gut, ja.
Es bleibt dabei,
wir haben eigentlich ein gutes Gespräch geführt.
Aber auch jetzt in diesem Gespräch,
ergab sich dieses Verständigungsproblem.
Das ist jetzt viel verlangt,
dass Sie das von einer Minute auf die andere abstellen oder ändern.
Aber versuchen Sie mal wirklich ganz bewusst daran zu arbeiten,
die Sprache hinten aus dem Rachen rauszuholen.
Ich glaube, die Verständigkeit würde ganz, ganz stark profitieren davon.
Eine Sache,
das war das.
Was war das?
Ja, da bin ich immer nicht so begeistert,
wenn jemand sagt, bis auf
Appetitlosigkeit,
Gewichtsverlust und Schlafstörungen
ist die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig.
Also in dem Augenblick finde ich, ist die nicht mehr unauffällig.
Sondern eben die Frage nach der vegetativen Anamnese,
die man nach der vegetativen Anamnese ergab.
Und dann muss man die Punkte anrühren.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese sind Inapitans,
Gewichtsverlust, Insomnia, auffällig.
Inapitans wollen oder auffällig, ja, die auch immer.
Was ich gut fand,
dass Sie gleich zu Beginn,
als Sie praktisch über die Beschwerden der Patientin gesprochen haben,
gleich gesagt haben,
Sie müssen aber wissen, die Patientin ist vor vier Wochen operiert worden,
wegen eines barligenden Melanomus,
mit Lymphflotenentfernung.
Das ist einfach eine elementare Information,
die unbedingt dazugehört.
Natürlich ist dieser Fall, es ist übrigens ein Düsseldorferfall.
Ich weiß immer gar nicht, ob der überhaupt noch geprüft wird.
Ich finde ihn eigentlich so ein bisschen unrealistisch.
Weil die Chance, dass ihn so jemand in die Ambulanz reinschneidet,
in die Notfallambulanz,
mit so einer Vorgeschichte,
das kann eventuell am Wochenende oder am späten Abend passieren.
Ja, mag sein, ja.
Aber genau genommen gibt es immer,
für Leute, die nicht chemo haben,
die wissen genau, welche Medikamente sie bekommen.
Die haben Berichte,
die haben Vorbefunde dabei.
Ich denke mal, kein normaler Mensch
mit einer Krebsoperation,
egal ob es Haut oder sonst ein Krebs ist,
geht ohne Vorbefunde irgendwo zu einem anderen Arzt.
Ja?
Insofern denke ich,
weil es ist so ein klein wenig unrealistisch.
Aber irgendjemand hat gerade kurz eingeblendet,
das ist schwierigster Fall von Düsseldorf.
Wissen Sie, wird er noch gemacht?
Oder ist der hoffnungslos unaktuell?
Da muss ich ihn mal rausnehmen.
Ich habe keine Augenfreude.
Von habe ich erst mal gehört.
Ja, ich habe ihn schon oft gemacht, so ist es nicht.
Aber ist er ein aktueller Fall?
Ah ja, genau.
Sie macht in Düsseldorf ihre Prüfung, genau.
Er wird tatsächlich noch bedient.
Trotzdem finde ich ihn nicht besonders realistisch.
Aber da wir auch immer viele Düsseldorfer haben,
Hatice war das gerade eben.
Hatice, wir haben den Fall zusammengemacht im Februar.
Kann das sein?
Letzten Jahres?
Oder war das eine andere Hatice?
Das könnte natürlich sein.
Das ist der Fall.
Sie ist über alles informiert.
Der Fall ist tatsächlich noch im Programm drin.
Er wird noch geboten.
Es gibt ihn noch, obwohl er ein bisschen unrealistisch ist.
Okay, so viel für heute.
Freiburg war heute Feiertag?
Ja, heute ist Feiertag.
Er war nicht mehr.
Heute ist Feiertag.
Ja, aber die machen die katholischen und die evangelischen Feiertage.
Ja, in einigen Bundesländern ist Arbeitstag heute.
Ja, und wir hatten heute auch frei.
Aber bei mir war irgendwie viel los heute.
Ja, gut.
Schön, dass wir uns gesehen haben.